it's great to welcome back to the
program Larry Norden who's deputy
director of the democracy program at NYU
Law School's Brennan Center for Justice
you know Larry for all the talk about
what took place during the last election
and sort of the importance of these
midterm elections depending on what your
political views are there's surprisingly
little discussion of what has been done
to ensure election integrity in these
midterms that are coming up in November
so I mean I guess first big picture it
for us
rate your confidence that we're going to
have full and fair elections in November
of 2018 mm-hmm well I think a good place
to start when we're talking about this
is what we mean by election interference
that that term gets used a lot
particularly as applies to the 2016
election and it can mean a number of
things so in 2016 we know that the
Russians Kremlin directed purchased
political planets on sorry that
purchased political ads on platforms
like Facebook and Google and Twitter and
elsewhere and that's something that
we've gotten somewhat of a handle on the
government hasn't necessarily done all
that much
I expect that we're likely to see some
more of that stuff but that the social
media companies themselves have done a
little bit more about that so that at
least if it and when that happens again
in the 2016 election and every reason to
believe that will as I said it'll be
it'll be a little bit more obvious and
advocacy groups the public reporters can
call that out when it happens so that's
one aspect I think when you talk about
election integrity a lot of people talk
about election integrity they mean a
second aspect which is the election
infrastructure itself and there again
there are there are a few parts to that
there there are the voting machines
which i think is what most people go to
immediately
when they think about is somebody
messing with our elections through
cyberattacks and making sure that those
are recording votes accurately but there
are also many other election systems
that we use to conduct elections there
the registration systems right that's
what tells us who is entitled and not
not entitled to go vote on those
machines in the first place there are
electronic poll books that might be used
in polling places that we use to to
provide that registration data in the
polling place on Election Day of their
election websites which might tell
people what polling places to go to and
also provide election night reporting to
vote totals and we need to protect all
of those so in terms of how confident I
am I we're doing much more than we ever
had to secure that election
infrastructure in part in response to
the 2016 election there are far more
cyber trainings of election officials to
make them aware of how to defend the
systems Congress recently allocated 380
million dollars to the states to spend
on election system security and and
there have been upgrades that have been
happening at the state and county level
of these various systems having said all
that we're not doing as much as I would
like and certainly you can I can point
to specific things ahead of the 2018
election that I'd like to see happen
that probably aren't going to happen and
and and I think we really need to push
for ahead of 2020 most obviously we
still have paperless voting machines in
the US which election system security
experts are nearly unanimous the
Department of Homeland Security in the
intelligence agencies the intelligence
committees from the Senate and the house
have said these need to be replaced with
systems that produce a paper record so
that if there is some kind of intrusion
against these systems we can detect it
and we have a backup record that we can
use to to make sure that votes are
accurate so a lot of those along those
lines if I if I can
I've been here with a few school
questions when we talked about the
reports that although there's no
evidence that vote totals were changed
by any kind of Russian targeting of
voting systems that those systems in 21
states at least 21 states were targeted
it appears as though in it in at least
one case Russian agents were able to
access those systems and exactly what
that means I guess is something we could
discuss when you talk about having a
paper verification of what votes were
cast is that a mechanism that would help
to counteract whatever it is that might
be done through the intrusions that were
attempted in 21 States or are we talking
about two different things there yeah I
want to be clear about this because this
gets really confusing especially the
people that don't spend a lot of time in
elections or studying elections from
everything we know that's been reported
about those 21 states those were not
attacks on voting machines those were
not attempts to break into voting
machines they were attempts there were
either attempts to scan or to breach
either registration systems or election
websites right that's not their votes
are counted and totaled the one breach
that we know about and actually there
was a Senate Intelligence Committee
report that indicated that it was more
than one state that had a breach they
didn't say how many they said a small
number but one state that we do know
about is Illinois and that was there a
breach in to their registration system
and there was apparently an attempt to
change some information in the
registration rules that was unsuccessful
now you can imagine if somebody was
successful in changing the roles the
registration roles that that would be
that could cause a lot of problems if
you know names are removed from a list
or address exchange so that when they
show up to the polling place they're not
listed in the poll books that that could
create problems a person it might create
long lines the person should be given a
provisional ballot but unless they
figure out what happened that ballot
might not be counted so it's really
important that states have have backups
of all of the registry
information and that they're auditing it
that they're checking it and if there
are problems that there's some way to go
back and figure out who should have been
able to vote and to count those votes
now that's completely separate from the
other issue that that we were just
talking about which is the voting
machines themselves now those you know
it is theoretically possible that you
could have malicious software reach
those machines it's theoretically
possible that those machines could
report incorrect results because they're
running on software and that's where
having a paper record now there's no
evidence that that happened I want to be
clear in the 2016 election right but
that's something that we want to be
really concerned about and we want to
make sure that we have something in
place that will allow us to detect if
that happened and allow us to recover if
that happened and the best something in
place that we could have our paper
records that the voter fills out or
reviews that we know the voter said this
is my vote since you work on on this
issue from a few angles Larry I'm
curious and if this starts to get beyond
sort of your focus by up by all means
tell us that that you're sort of
speculating but if you were another
country and your goal was to alter what
would be the natural result of an
election in the United States what would
actually be the most pragmatic path to
that would it be trying to actually
change vote tallies in machines to the
extent that it's theoretically possible
would it be disinformation campaigns
through social media to actually get
people to vote in a different way what
what like I guess what I'm trying to say
is if we want to think about how we're
most vulnerable to the election results
being altered what are the actual most
effective paths to that if you're a
foreign entity you know one thing one
thing I want to be clear about actually
I think the good starting point is to
look at what the Russian specifically
have done in other countries because
they have interfered far more directly
in other countries elections in Eastern
Europe than they
than they apparently did in the United
States in 2016 and one of the things
that the Intelligence Agency's
intelligence community has told us and
the Senate Intelligence Committee said
this as well
primary objective of the Russians
wherever they've operated is just
undermine confidence in the system in
general right in 2016 they actually did
have an additional goal of of favoring
one candidate in the presidential race
over another but but their their
overarching goal always is just to sow
distrust in the system and and what the
Russians have done elsewhere pretty
clearly is they have targeted election
night reporting websites that deal with
reporting either turnout or vote totals
that wouldn't necessarily at the end of
the day change the outcome of the
election if you have the kinds of
redundancies that we have in place in
the United States but they would do an
awful sorry about my light there no
problem we can see it could have a big
impact on casting doubt in the election
outcomes and if you combine that with
social media and again if you look at
what the the Facebook ads that were just
released that the Russians had paid for
in the 2016 election some of them were
focused on how you just can't trust the
system there's no point in voting so
there's this this just general flow of
information that is meant to cast doubt
on the entire objective of liberal
democracy so that's point one now going
to if I actually wanted to go in and
change the results of have some impact
on changing the results of an election
look there's election night reporting we
tally all our votes from teens generally
in a central place in a county of a
state and so I might target those but
again there
didn't cease so you have you know a
County might be reporting its votes that
come in from all these polling places
but then you have the individual
appalling places and machines that are
reporting results so there's a good
chance that you might that you would if
you have the procedures in place catch
if there was at the county level of a
state level with the tallies what we
call tally servers if somehow those
numbers worker were incorrect that you
would find them and of course again
going back to what I said earlier that
might be if you're if you're Russia and
you're trying to undermine confidence in
the system that might be good enough and
you know if I wanted to go after the
voting machines where votes are counted
the most obvious place to go would be
where there were no paper records so you
wouldn't have this independent record to
check and and you know this doesn't take
a specialist in elections to understand
you know you took you would target
critical counties and battleground
states if we're doing something like a
presidential election and hope for the
best in the limited time we have left
other than the paper records of the
ballots that are cast what would be the
other one or two things that you'd like
changed well one thing for sure and and
this is something that the Senate
Intelligence Committee in its report
emphasized is is doing thorough
vulnerability assessments this is
something that the Department of
Homeland Security offers it looks at the
entire system and basically says here is
where your weaknesses are you need to
understand where your weaknesses are and
fix them and that could be in the
registration system it could be an
election websites it could be in you
know in the voting machines themselves
in the way that you're totaling results
and reporting them understanding all of
that is and where the weaknesses are is
really important and only 14 states last
I checked had undertaken this kind of
vulnerability assessment through DHS the
really detailed one so it that's number
one I'd like to see more states doing
that secondly is just upgrading
infrastructure more generally voting
machines are really old in the United
States we've got 43 states that are
using machines that are no longer
manufactured
which too often means election officials
of buying spare parts on eBay which I
don't think is particularly safe you
could say the same thing about
registration databases forty states are
using databases that were created well
over a decade ago they may be running on
meticulous oft where if it's no longer
vendor supported which means it's not
getting the kind of security patches
that it should so just a general
investment in upgrading those things
three hundred eighty million dollars
that Congress just gave to the states as
a start for that kind of upgrade but we
definitely need more money than that
Larry Norton deputy director of the
democracy program at NYU Law School's
Brennan Center for Justice Larry thanks
for talking to us about this again
thanks as always thanks for having me on